when we think of Prophecy we think of
finding a verse that says a virgin will
conceive or from Bethlehem out of you
shall come the ruler no prophecy is more
than that if you understand the New
Testament and even how the Jews
understood the Old Testament even the
Jews understood the entire Old Testament
these events were set up to point to
future events so an event in the past
was designed an actual historical event
that happened it's a real historical
event but it's designed in such a way to
point to a future event that's even
greater a greater reality yet death
Reign Romans 5:14 yet death Reign from
Adam to Moses even over those whose sins
were not like the transgression of Adam
who is a type of the one was to come it
says Adam was a type he was designed to
be a type a shadow of the one who was to
come in other words Adam is a picture of
Jesus that means you have to look to
Adam to see how he points to Christ but
the type will never be as great as the
anti-type meaning the shadow will never
be as great as the reality the reality
will always be greater so though Adam is
a picture of Christ Christ is greater so
let me show you how Adam resembles
Jesus according to the scriptures the
holy spirit is likened to water John 7
38-39 he who believes in me as the
scripture has said out of his heart
shall flow rivers of Living Water rivers
of Living Water so who or what is water
now this he said about the spirit which
those who believed in him were to
receive for as yet the spirit had not
been given because Jesus was not yet
glorified so notice Rivers Living Water
that's holy Spirit holy spirit is water
liken to Living Water okay Jesus born of
a virgin the Virgin Mary conceived by
the Holy Spirit Matthew
1:18 Matthew 1:20 Jesus conceived of a
virgin from the Holy Spirit Matthew 1118
Matthew 120 that means Mary's virgin
womb was watered by the Holy Spirit
spiritually right so the spirit Came
Upon her the holy Spirit Came Upon dry
ground her womb virgin soil and watered
it and she conceived a baby now why do I
say her womb is dry ground dry soil like
the Earth because that's what Psalm says
in Psalm 139 13- 16 it Likens our
formation our conception in our mother's
womb to being fashioned from the earth
psalm
139: 13- 16 it says that when we are
fashioned in our mother's womb that's us
being fashioned from the earth for thou
you did form my inward Parts you did
knit me together in my mother's womb I
praise you for you are fearful and
wonderful wonderful are your works you
know me right well my frame was not
hidden from you when I was being made in
secret when you were intricately woing
me in the depths of the Earth
verse 15 you and I being fashioned our
mother's womb is God fashioning you from
the earth okay the eyes your eyes beheld
my unformed substance and your book were
written every one of them the days that
were formed for me yet as yet there was
none of them we who are fashioned in our
mother's womb the womb of our mothers is
the earth that we were fashioned and
came out
of like Adam and by the way this is one
of the passages we use to show that
abortion is murder murdering a baby in
the womb is murder now why is that
important now think about it Jesus being
fashioned in his mother's womb a virgin
that means he came out of Virgin soil
virgin ground
virgin land the land was virgin virgin
soil no one had toiled no one had
cultivated it and that virgin ground
that he came out of was watered by the
Holy Spirit now how does this liken him
to Adam Genesis 2: 47 let's see who's
going to pay attention in the day that
the Lord God yahwah made the earth and
the heavens when no plant of the field
was yet in the earth notice no
plant no herb of the field had yet
spring up why for the Lord yahwah God
had not caused it to rain so it was dry
soil it hadn't been rained upon and
there was no man to till the ground did
you catch it it was virgin soil there
wasn't a man that plowed into it that
cultivated it no man had plowed into the
ground its virgin soil but a Mist went
up from the earth and watered the whole
face of the ground now remember the holy
spirit's like into water then the Lord
God formed man of dust from the ground
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life and Man became a living
Soul Adam was born of Virgin soil that
was watered by a
the last Adam was born of Virgin soil
that was watered by the holy spirit so
the first Adam was born of a virgin the
last Adam was born out a virgin now let
me show you how Adam and Eve become a
picture of Christ in the church in John
19 Jesus dies John 19:30 to 34 then it
says the soldiers came seeing him dead
there were shock they pierced his side
with a spear and from his side
flowed blood and water water and blood
now blood and water there's also a
medical reason for that but the blood
and water signify the blood that Jesus
sheds for forgiveness of sin and the
water remember what it represents the
Holy Spirit John 7
3839 that if you believe in him you will
have rivers of Liv water meaning you'll
have the Holy Spirit watering you the
blood and water are the two elements
that you need to be born again United to
Christ and part of his church his bride
without the blood cleansing you and the
water of the Holy Spirit causing you to
be born from above you cannot be part of
the church and therefore you're not the
bride of Christ because in 1 John 1:7
we're told the blood of Jesus Christ
cleanses us from all
sin okay and you must be born of water
and spirit and he who believes in me as
the scripture says out of his belly will
flow rivers of Living Water of this he
spoke of the Holy Spirit
so Jesus died SE side pierced and from
his side the two living elements blood
and water came out because it's the
death of Christ that brings your
forgiveness and it's the death of Christ
that gives you the gift of the holy
spirit because without jesus' death you
will not receive the Holy Spirit now in
John 11: 11- 15 we're told that death is
likened to sleep in John 11 11-5 as well
as in 1 Thessalonians 4 13 to18 it says
those who are dead in Christ are
asleep and then we're told that when
Lazarus died Jesus said in John 11 11-15
our friend Lazarus has fallen asleep so
they thought he's asleep so they go okay
then he'll wake up then Jesus plainly
said our friend Lazarus has died death
sleep sleep a metaphor for death so
Jesus died he was put into a deep sleep
from which his side was cut cut open
from
which he received his bride why because
now notice the other connection with
Adam okay watch the other
connection all right get ready because
now you're going to see how it connects
with Jesus let me just get Ephesians
ready as well Ephesians 530 to 32
Genesis 22124 remember
sleep metaphor for death so the Lord God
caused a deep sleep to fall upon the man
Adam went to a deep
sleep Jesus went to a deep
sleep and while he
slept
right while he was asleep took one of
his ribs now guys go look at the Hebrew
cah I believe it means side the word for
rib also means side so the Lord cut open
the side of Adam and from that side he
then fashioned his bride and then he
closed up that side with flesh and the
rib what he took from his side which the
Lord God had taken from the man he made
into a woman and brought her to the man
wait so like Jesus Adam was put into a
deep sleep like Jesus his sight was cut
open from which he received his bride
just like Jesus but now to prove to you
that this was designed to be a picture
of Jesus so I'm not making it up that
from Genesis was designing story of Adam
to point to Jesus in The church here
then the man said this at last is bone
of my bones and Flesh of My Flesh she
shall be called
woman from the womb of man because she
was taken out of man therefore a man
leaves his father and his mother and
Cleaves to his wife and they become one
flesh now let me prove to you that this
story a true historical event was
designed to point to Christ because God
did all things with the view of Christ
coming into the world why watch Paul
quoting Genesis 2:24 and applying it not
to Adam and Eve but to Christ and his
church Ephesians
53-32 and if you read the majority text
King James new King James it says
because we are member of his body flesh
of his flesh bone of his bones who Jesus
and then notice What It quotes for this
reason a man shall leave his father and
mother and be joined to his wife and the
two shall become one flesh this is a
great mystery and I mean in reference to
Christ and the church see what Paul said
Paul said Genesis
2:24 was meant to be a picture of Christ
and his church like Eve is a member of
Adam's Body flesh of his flesh bone of
his bones we the church are members of
Christ's body because we are flesh of
his flesh bone of his bones because Adam
and Eve were pointing to Christ and his
church Adam Jesus born a virgin Adam
Jesus put in a deep sleep and their
sight cut open to receive their bride by
the way this also tells you how
medically accurate the Bible is if you
want to perform surgery you put people
under deep sleep
anesthesia God put Adam in a deep sleep
because when you're in a deep sleep you
can be cut open and you don't feel the
pain there you have in Genesis a
precursor to Anesthesia now remember the
church is Eve but so is the Blessed
Mother because now I'm going to blow you
away here's where you're going to see
God dignifying women the first Adam the
woman came out of him
right yes okay the first Adam the woman
came out of him but the last Adam was he
greater but the last Adam was greater
came out of a woman just like the first
Adam the woman came out of him the last
Adam came out of a woman but not a man
so the last Adam who's the greater Adam
came out of a woman alone and yet the
first Adam who wasn't as great the woman
came out of him this is how women are
being digifi because someone can say
well the woman came out of man to help
man and then people can misinterpret
that to show she's inferior she's not
because remember what Adam said she's
Flesh of My Flesh bone of my bones and
Together We Are One flesh but the
greater Adam who is infinitely Superior
to Adam all creation because he's God In
the Flesh he came out of a woman so you
see how now it's being reversed the
Lesser and the greater the Lesser is
Adam and Eve is the Lesser and the
greater is the one to come and the one
who is greater comes out of a woman
showing you the dignity that women have
because it's a woman who gives birth to
the greater Adam who redeems man whereas
the first Adam plunged us into death y
okay now let's continue a little
further Eve is called woman in the
garden
right yes Eve is called woman in the
garden and she was a virgin right
because Adam and Eve did not have sex
until they were thrown out because Adam
knew Eve sexually after they're thrown
out Genesis 4 he got pregnant right
right okay so follow with me Eve called
woman a virgin ate fruit from a fidden
tree and gave birth to death the other
virgin gave birth to the fruit of her
womb who hung on a tree
and hanging on the tree he brought life
two
virgins one ate forbidden fruit of a
forbidden tree and gave birth to death
the other virgin the fruit of her womb
hung on a tree and he was the antidote
and cure of death so she gave birth to
life where am I getting that Jesus is
the fruit of Mary's womb hung on a tree
I'm getting it from the Bible here let
me show you Luke 1 41-45 and when
Elizabeth heard
the greeting of Mary The Babe leaped in
her womb and Elizabeth was filled with
the Holy Spirit and she exclaimed with a
loud cry blessed are you among women and
blessed is the fruit of your
womb Jesus is the fruit of her womb and
he hung on a tree and I'll show it to
you and WIS this granted me that the
mother of my Lord should come to me so
notice he had just been conceived
showing you conception begins life
begins at conception because she had
just conceived them about a week earlier
and Elizabeth already knew by the Holy
Spirit she already conceived her Lord
and that it was her Lord in her womb
notice the mother of my Lord what honor
is this that you are carrying my Lord
you are the mother of my Lord and you're
here and even my baby in my womb filled
with the spirit when he heard your voice
left because he recognized who you are
the mother of my Lord why is this
granted me that the mother of my Lord
should come to me for behold when the
voice of your greeting came to my ears
The Babe in my womb Le for Joy a babe
who's only six months old in the womb
filled with the Holy Spirit In the Womb
Luke 115 Elizabeth filled with the Holy
Spirit Luke 141 when Mary entered and
greeted even the baby recognize that's
the voice of the mother my Lord because
my Lord is in her belly did he hang on a
tree yeah acts 5:30 the god of our
fathers raised Jesus whom you killed by
hanging him on a tree there's the fruit
hanging on the tree making that tree the
Tree of
Life acts 10:39 and we are witnesses to
all that he did both in the country of
the Jews and in Jerusalem they put him
to death by hanging him on a tree the
fruit of the Virgin hanging on the tree
and now that's the Tree of Life
acts
13:29 and when they had fulfilled all
that was written of him they took him
down from the tree and laid him in a
tomb the Virgin Mary gave birth to her
fruit her fruit hung on the tree making
it the Tree of Life soever eats that
fruit he eats my flesh and drinks my
blood has life one virgin ate forbidden
fruit brought death the other virgin
gave birth to fruit that hung on the
tree making the tree of life that if you
eat that you will live two virgins two
trees two fruit in Genesis 3 death
entered the world in a garden then if
you read Genesis
3 22-
24 you will see that God threw them out
of the garden barring them from the Tree
of Life and place cherubim with flaming
swords there was a flaming sword and
cherubim cherubim are Spirit creatures
that's at least two if you read John 19
38-42 Jesus was buried in a garden tomb
the Tomb of Jesus was in a
garden when Mary Magdalene came on
Sunday she entered the garden there were
two angels in the garden two angels and
then the tomb was
empty she went back and told the
disciples the tomb is empty and she came
back because she was weeping bitterly
Jesus stood before her and then it says
in John thinking him to be the
gardener he said woman why do You Weep
did you catch it she thought he was the
gardener but if you go to Genesis 2 and
you read Adam the first man was a
gardener because he was created to care
for the Garden of Eden So Adam was The
Gardener of the Garden of Eden here's
the last Adam in a garden and then Mary
thinks he's the gardener So Adam The
Gardener Jesus The Gardener in the
Garden of Eden two cherub them in the
garden in which Jesus rises from the
dead two angels and she thinks he's the
gardener now did you catch it death
entered the world in a garden the
destruction of death immortality enter
the world in a garden because Christ
conquered death by his resurrection on
on the third day where he rose to life
in a garden because he was in a tomb so
he walked out of the Tomb in a garden
destroying death in a garden
reversal what happened in Eden Reverse
by Jesus that's why then you see
something
amazing woman why do You Weep does that
sound familiar because in Genesis 3 Eve
was called woman and by eating the f
forbidden Bru fruit she brought mourning
and weeping and misery so here is Mary
who's weeping because of death the death
of her Lord a death that occurred
because of sin and then now he calls her
woman and echo of Genesis 3 woman in
Genesis 3 Mary Magdalene woman in John
20 and now he destroys death removing
weeping Mourning and misery okay but
wait I'm not done with Mary
yet remember Jesus is the fruit of her
womb right Luke
142 right Luke 142 Elizabeth blessed are
you among women blessed is the fruit of
thy womb
right now watch how Eve becomes a
picture of the Virgin Genesis 314- 15
the Lord God said to the serpent the
Lord God said to the serpent because you
have done this cursed are you above all
cattle and above all wild animals upon
your belly you shall go and dust you
shall eat all the days of your life I
will put enmity between you and the
woman did you guys catch it my brothers
he didn't say I wouldn't put enmity
between you and the
man I will put hatred between you and
the woman and between your seed and her
seed not your seed and the man's seed he
shall bruise your head and you shall
bruise his he so God is saying the seed
of the woman not of the man is going to
crush your head her seed will crush your
head and you're going to be at war with
her he didn't say you're going to be at
war with Adam you know it's
ironic the only man who was the seed of
the woman literally the seed of the
woman because no man SED him is Jesus
Galatians 4:4 in the fullness of time
God sent forth his son born of a woman
born under the law the the only literal
seed of a woman is Jesus everyone else
comes from a woman through a man by a
man he's the only one who is literally
the seed of a woman no man siring him so
he is actually the literal seed of the
woman alone and not the seed of the man
so why because God is going to now paint
a picture of that one seed who will be
the seed of the woman not of a man
because Jesus literally fulfills Genesis
3:15 because he's literally the seed of
the woman and not of a man so that Eve
is a picture of Mary being the woman who
gives birth to a seed without a
man now let's continue a little further
now notice what's ironic here in Genesis
3:20 the man called his wife's name
k because she was the mother of all
living kava
from life but now I'm confused why would
Adam call Eve living when she just
brought death because remember what Paul
said in Romans 5:14 Adam was a picture
of
Christ right that means Eve is a picture
of the woman who is the mother of all
living why because is Jesus called life
in John
1:4 yes in him was life in John 14:6 I
am the way the truth and the life in
John 11:25 I'm the resurrection and the
life Colossians 34 Christ Our Life acts
3:15 the author of life so who literally
gave birth to Life In the Flesh Mary
because what does first John 1 1 and2
say Jesus is the Word of Life the
eternal life the life Mary carried in
her womb eternal life the life The Word
of Life the author of life so life
became flesh so she truly is the mother
of all living because life entered her
womb became flesh to die for us to give
us life so what is said of Eve is
actually a
foreshadowing of what is true about Mary
the mother of all living because from
whom wom came the light who through the
flesh he took from her flesh in that
flesh he died to pay your debt to set
you free okay but I'm going to leave you
now the final point to see if you get
the
connection I will put hatred between you
The Serpent and the woman doesn't even
say the man the war is between him and
the
woman and your seed and her seed you
will crush his heel and it'll crush your
head now the word seed is a collective
singular it's referring to not only one
person but a group United to Christ how
do I know Romans
16:20 who is the seed that crushes the
head of Satan then the God of Peace will
soon Crush Satan under your
feet so God said we the church who are
one with Christ born of the spirit we
are the seed whose feet will be used by
Christ to crush Satan's head Romans
16:20 then the God of Peace will soon
Crush Satan under your feet the grace of
our Lord Jesus Christ be with you all
right your feet whose feet the feet of
the church that's also Luke 101
17-20 Luke 101 17- 20 and the 70 return
72 returned rejoicing saying Lord even
the demons submit to us in your name and
Jesus said I saw Satan fall like
lightning from Heaven I have given
you you you my followers authority to
trample scorpions snakes is Jesus
talking about Believers being authorized
to crush physical snakes and scorpions
under their feet because even
unbelievers can do that right yes so
what does it mean I have given you my
Believers the power to crush trample
that's Genesis 3:15 trample under your
feet snakes scorpions scorpion snakes
who are these scorpions and snakes these
demons in the lands outside of Israel
only outside Israel so there are no
demons in Israel and in Israel of course
and then to prove it and no har no power
of the enemy will harm you it's not
about demons and Satan but do not
rejoice in this that the demons are
subject to you but rather Rejoice that
your names are written in heaven so the
Scorpions and snakes are Satan and
demons who will be crushed by the feet
of Believers by the authority of Christ
so did everyone see the seed of the
woman is not just Christ it's Christ and
all who believe in him whom he will then
Empower by his authority and death to
crush Satan and demons under our feet if
we belong to him remember it says the
fruit of her womb hung on a tree right
is Jesus the fruit of Mary's womb Luke
1:42 did he hang on a tree yes Acts 5:30
acts 1039 13:29 was that the tree that
Jesus used to crush the Serpent's head
yes okay abely let me ask you this John
1925-27 remember in the garden she's
called woman right the soldiers did this
but standing by the cross there's that
tree of Jesus were his mother and his
mother's Sister Mary the wife of clus
and Mary Magdalene so Jesus is on the
cross acts 5:30 calls the cross the tree
his mother's there Jesus is the fruit of
her womb Luke 1:42 so here's the fruit
of her womb hanging on the tree and that
becomes the tree of life now watch
remember in Genesis 3 she's called woman
what does Jesus call Mary this is why
these Bible butcher the these perverts
Think Jesus was dishonoring Mary because
they're too stupid to see Jesus was
using the language to show you here's
the woman and her seed of Genesis 3 and
Mary Magdalene when Jesus saw his mother
watch and the disciple whom he loved
standing near he said to his motherwoman
behold your son here's the seed I and
all who believe in me are your seed
woman because you gave birth to the seed
who now crushes the head of the serpent
through my body the church then he said
to his disciple behold your mother and
from that hour the disciple took her to
his own home there you go now one more
thing it says that the serpent will
strike the heel of the seed and the the
seed will crush his head
right okay now notice the Symmetry if a
serpent gets close enough to your heel
that means he's now close enough to your
foot so you can crush his head right
right exactly in Genesis 3:15 you will
strike his heel and he'll crush your
head now if a poisonous serpent bites
your heel you die don't you yep so
notice he's going to strike a mortal
wound he's going to bite the heel and
because it's poisonous he dies but now
he's close enough for the seed to crush
his head because if he bites my heel now
I can trample it with my foot right
exactly okay now remember it it points
to Jesus and Believers that means the
serpent would inflict a mortal blow a
deadly wound to Jesus when did the
serpent bite Jesus's heel resulting in
his
death n Inch Nails so on the cross yes
sir so but now that means that if he bit
Jesus's heel I.E caused him to die by
the cross that means now he's close
enough for Christ to crush his head
right right so if the cross was Satan's
bite that means the cross is also sat's
destruction right right now can you
explain to me is it a coincidence in
John
1917 it says so they took Jesus John
19:17 and he went out bearing his own
cross
to the place called the place of a skull
which is called in Hebrew Goa is it a
coincidence that when Christ was
crucified that upright pole was situated
in a hill that looked like a head so
that if you saw that pole with the Cross
Beam it would look from your Vantage
Point as you're looking at it that the
pole is going through the head that
mound that head that was piercing
through it is that a coincidence or is
that a picture here is the Serpent's
head and I'm crushing and piercing his
skull his head by the cross